[Musique]
messieurs bienvenue à 24,60 hors série
comment transformer une maladie
incurable une maladie qu'on connaît trop
bien peut-être pas assez bien
l'alzheimer en un projet de vie lumineux
et plein d'espoir ces chemins que
blandine prévost a choisi il y a dix ans
elle a reçu ce diagnostic d'alzheimer
elle n'avait que 36 ans mère de famille
ingénieur c'est mon invité ce soir
bonsoir blandine prévost monfort il est
accompagné de nicole poirier fondatrice
de la maison carpediem à trois rivières
vous êtes toutes les deux des personnes
qui avaient témoigné à ce grand forum
sur l'aide médicale à mourir qui s'est
tenue à quelques jours à montréal
très heureux de vous accueillir sur ce
plateau blandine bravo parce que parler
à quelqu'un ouvertement presque
sereinement de cette maladie parce que
vous vivez avec cette maladie déjà
depuis dix ans vous témoignez de votre
projet de vie
d'abord commençons par ce diagnostic
comment l avez-vous découvert ce
diagnostic
alors tout d'abord c'est une maladie
progressive et donc les difficultés
elles apparaissent peu à peu dans la vie
et puis on se dit qu'on est fatigué
qu'on a on a tous tous oublié un jour
d'acheter le pain et c'est pas pour ça
qu'on est malade et puis petit à petit
on voit que
les difficultés augmentent alors moi
j'ai mis en place des choses pour pour
essayer de de continuer à vivre de
continuer à faire mon travail
d'ingénieur et puis un moment donné les
difficultés prennent toute la place et
est en tout cas dans le cadre du travail
il était possible que je travaille je ne
pouvais plus j'avais mis en place tout
ce que je pouvais pour réussira à
vaincre ses difficultés et je n'y arrive
plus et donc c'est que là que le la
démarche vers le diagnostic il va il a
fallu que j'en parle à mon mari indien
je crois qu'il ya un problème mais et
c'est là que la démarche est intervenu
en fait et vous avez vu votre père
lui-même souffrir de cette maladie
comment on reçoit un choc comme celui là
comment ça se passe est ce qu'on reçoit
un choc comme je vous le disais c'est
quelque chose qui arrive peu à peu dans
la vie donc on a peur on est très très
seul au début de la maladie parce que on
essaye de ne pas le montrer et on a peur
que ce soit ça moi la première je disais
c'est ça doit être psychologique puisque
papa à ça serait quand même pas de bol
que j'ai la même chose la fatigue le
burn out et c'est donc la maladie les
difficultés on prend l'habitude de vivre
avec elles font partie de notre vie en
fait et donc je sais que il ya des
choses qu'il faut que je fasse sinon je
vais être perdu et comment mais il faut
être fou de fait très forte baisse ou
être très fort pour arriver à
transformer ce diagnostic qui est
implacable en un projet de vie comme
vous l'avez fait parce que vous
témoignez vous avait déjà parlé tout à
l'heure avec mon emploi et vous allez
démarrer une maison à grenoble vous avez
j'en avais fait un projet de vie non pas
centré sur vous aussi sur les autres
vous vous parler de la maladie donc vous
aider les autres comment on
il va faire un projet de vue ou si
important de cette mallette et je pense
qu'il ya des gens je suis pas tout seul
un jeu c'est pas c'est pas moi je suis
accompagné par un mari extra et des
enfants extraordinaires et c'est avec
nos amis qu'on a décidé qui à l'annoncé
du diagnostic
j'ai tout de suite demandé quelles
étaient les solutions pour moi plus tard
et on m'a répondu soit l'ehpad
donc pour vous les culs allant de votre
c'est h celle d où elle soit l'hôpital
psychiatrique
j'ai rien contre ça mais pour l'avoir
vécu côté famille
je trouve que c'est je savais que
c'était culpabilisant et c'était parce
que je voulais pour mes enfants et mon
mari je voulais qu'ils puissent que
c'est que la maladie ne gagne pas que au
delà de ma maladie mes enfants puissent
vivre libres
totalement libre je suis profondément
attaché à cette liberté et pour ça il
fallait qu'on trouve une solution
alors soit c'est le suicide ou
l'euthanasie soit c'est essayer de d'en
faire quelque chose et est donc assez
vite on s'est dit on est passés avec
xavier mon mari du pourquoi nous au
pourquoi faire et là où on a mis on a on
a interpellé nos amis en disant voilà on
va essayer de créer un lieu pas un lieu
une maison où serait bien et où qui
permettra je pourrais aller et venir
librement ou serait respectée jusqu'au
bout et ainsi tout le monde pourra vivre
librement et le poids de la maladie la
maladie aura à gagner
elle pèsera plus autant sur ma vie et
sur la vie de mes enfants et pour ça on
a eu la chance de tomber sur carpediem
où on s'est rendu compte que ce qu'on
rêvait ça existait donc à partir de ce
moment là il y avait plus une barrière
cela vous intervenez à nicole poirier
parce qu'effectivement dans un prévôt
apprend à vivre avec sa maladie apprend
à faire les efforts qu'il faut c'est là
vous intervenez oui moi je suis surtout
intervenus par pour aider blandine et
xavier dans leurs projets de
construction de maison oui petit à petit
on est devenus amis et la vie
quotidienne je la partage quand je lis
quand je joue bien et je peux la
soutenir dans le quotidien
qu'est ce que c'est justement la vie
quotidienne pour vous maintenant est ce
que vous êtes confrontés à la perception
que les gens ont de la maladie des
personnes atteintes de la maladie
la perception que les gens ont de la
maladie vous voulez que les gens
perçoivent comme des personnes n'a pas
capable de vivre et dans votre réalité
c'est la chose la plus dure avec
peut-être pas la plus dure je suis c'est
le regard des autres le fait qu'on
disparaisse avec la maladie quand vous
avez le diagnostic
tout d'un coup là vous êtes plus que
maladie c'est à dire que tout ce qui
vous arrive sa peine 6 vous avez un
rhume c'est la faute de la maladie vous
êtes angoissé c'est de la faute de la
main disent non c'est pas toujours de la
faute de la maladie non on peut avoir
aussi d'autres causes comme tout le
monde
peut-être que je suis agacé je suis
fatigué juste et c'est pas la maladie il
faut pas vouloir tout faire et c'est ça
la plus difficile c'est tout passe par
on devient on
on n'existe plus en tant que personne on
est plus qu'un malade alors je me bat
mais bat pour que on nous regarde comme
des personnes avec une maladie avec une
différence mais de manière bienveillante
bienveillant d'ailleurs dans un discours
que vous avez prononcé au fil des années
vous êtes quelque chose
de très intéressante qui nous aide à
comprendre ce que vous vivez
non pour moi je n'ai pas oublié moi je
ne les ai pas vécu alors que pour nous
on vous regarde il a des pertes de
mémoire où elles ont des pertes de
mémoire mais pour vous vous avez votre
monde avait une réalité à vivre qui est
très différente d'une certaine manière
n'est ce pas oui c'est c'est encore à
l'exemple du pain souvent les gens me
disent ah j'ai oublié oublier des choses
je j'oublie des choses que je crois que
je suis malade peut-être mais moi quand
j'oublie des choses c'est pas elles
n'ont pas existé
c'est à dire que vraiment ça n'a pas
existé
c'est alors ça peut être triste puisque
il ya des fois où où je on réalise pas
ce qu'on vit là on mange la vie par les
deux bouts quand on sait que la vie va
être plus courte et donc on réalise des
rêves
et puis on oublie qu'on les a réalisés
donc c'est compliqué on doit nous dire
ben je suis désolé mais on l'a déjà fait
eh bien il faut garder le sourire débat
peut le refaire on s'en est bien entouré
et bien aimée par votre entourage on
s'arrête quelque peu de sept minutes
blandine prévost et que le poirier
puis on poursuit cette conversation
absolument
émouvante et poignante et merci d'être
victime blonde a tout de suite aux
nominations
[Musique]
comment transformer le diagnostic d'une
maladie terrible maladie incurable en un
projet de vie lumineux généreux presque
serait mon invité blanc une prévaut est
atteinte de la maladie d'alzheimer
depuis dix ans la cac 40 il en est
accompagné de nicole poirier dans une
grille on poursuit notre conversation
quand on sait les six étaient je sentais
votre rage de vivre votre volonté de
vivre chaque instant de réaliser vos
rêves et vous avait déjà parlé de la
peur est-ce qu'on est habitée par la
peur au moment du diagnostic ou pas
lesquelles de quelle peur s'agit-il la
peur non les peurs la multitude de peur
la peur d'être un poids pour ses proches
la peur de changer à tel point qu'on se
reconnaît plus la peur de d'être enfermé
parce que c'est aujourd'hui la l'une des
options des options on nous enferme on
n'a rien fait la société mais on nous
enferme donc la peur d'être enfermé la
peur d'être un
d'être dépendants c'est pas facile
d'avoir besoin dead c'est pas facile de
vivre en ayant conscience que peu à peu
notre nos capacités intellectuelles
diminue et pour autant de rester debout
si jamais la peur de mourir la peur de
mourir non non jamais moi j'ai jamais eu
la peur de mourir
j'ai eu la peur de vivre de vivre
enfermé de vivre comme on me le
proposait de vivre en étant regarder
juste comme un poids et une charge par
la société
oui j'ai cette peur là c'est encore une
fois cette peur sans doute qu'à qui vous
a permis de développer le projet de
maison carpe diem en france et vous êtes
venu à montréal à ce forum sur la
musique allait mourir une grande
discussion actuellement sur la
possibilité de donner accès aux
personnes qui vont développer des
maladies dégénératives sup
intellectuelle neuro des nouveaux
cognitives oui et donc ne vous ne portez
pas de jugement il est des gens qui
veulent avoir le choix vous en avez
rencontré d'ailleurs des personnes qui
ont de l'alzheimer précoce pour vous et
qui voulait qu'ils auraient voulu avoir
accès à ce type de solutions j'ai
rencontré au début du projet on a essayé
de réfléchir à quelque chose qui serait
pas juste pour moi mais bien pour tous
on a rencontré beaucoup de personnes
malades et beaucoup m'ont dit
certains m'ont dit sue pas malade mais
j'ai prévu de me suicider comme ça et
d'autres m'ont dit oui j'ai des
difficultés je suis had et j'ai prévu de
ne susciter comme ça j'ai appris plein
façon mourir donc oui cette question du
suicide et de l'euthanasie se pose j'ai
moi même demandé à mon médecin de
m'aider en finir
quand sera venu le temps pour moi et m'a
répondu non
et alors j'ai la naïveté
c'est ça la naïveté de d'espérer que
c'est parce que ma vie vaut quelque
chose
même avec la maladie et pour les autres
et evry et et après chacun est libre de
choisir la façon dont il veut affronter
cette maladie et donc je jamais je ne
jugerai quelqu'un qui fait un autre
choix que le mien je pense qu'ils
essaient tous on a tous eu une façon de
combattre
vous m'avez fait promettre de vous faire
dire de me laisser dire que vous n'êtes
pas venu au québec pour faire la leçon
sur ce débat qui a cours parce que la
réflexion et elle est utile cette
réflexion-là selon vous sur le choix
possible d'accorder l'aide médicale à
mourir aux personnes qu'il ferait ce
choix éventuellement oui vraiment je
sais vraiment quelque chose de
fondamental pour moi je suis absolument
pas venu au québec pour dire quoi faire
comment faire c'est pas mon combat
ça c'est une réflexion des québécois et
que et moi j'ai absolument rien à faire
dans cette réflexion la shem mes
opinions mais j'ai a pas allé dire
puisque c'est une réflexion québécoise
moi je suis venu dire j'ai aux personnes
malades suivis
j'ai les mêmes peurs que vous j'ai
traversé la même chose que ce que vous
êtes en train de traverser mais moi ma
réponse j'ai trouvé ici au québec car
c'est carpediem et cette réponse là je
il faudrait que tous les québécois
la connaissent c'est tout je sais
carpediem qui qui fait qu'aujourd'hui je
suis devant vous et j'ai l'espoir la
certitude que jusqu'au bout je serai
libre d'aller et venir jusqu'au bout je
resterai respectée dans ce que je suis
et dans ce que j'ai été dans les
moindres détails
jamais je ne sortirais sans médaille
bourreau non c'est des détails mais je
sais que je vais je vais jusqu'au bout
moi même en fait qu on va respecter ce
que vous aimez convaincre louis
profondément mais ça c'est la proche
carpediem parce que oui alors justement
l'approchent carpediem on va en parler
après la pause nicole poirier dans un
très beau reste avec moins d'émissions
revient tous deux sous
[Musique]
je poursuis la conversation avec
blandine prévaut une école pour y
incorporer la fondatrice de carpe diem
modèle unique exporté en france grâce à
qui bon grâce à blandine prévaut une
personne atteinte de maladie d'alzheimer
qui n'a que 46 ans trois enfants et qui
a transformé son diagnostic en un projet
de ville en ce moment pour elle mais
pour toute une communauté pour en
regardant vers l'avenir pour les
personnes qui veulent vivre dans la
dignité jusqu'au bout comment avez vous
êtes interpellé par l'antenne prévue
nicole poirier
mais j'étais j'ai été interpellé par la
réalisatrice d'un film qui est un
documentaire qui avait été diffusée en
france laurent serfaty qui avaient fait
un autre reportage avec blandine et
xavier et puis quand blanc des nous
parle de son projet de maison où elle
aimerait aller vivre un jour laurent
serfaty au diable en d'une même votre
projet il existe et c'est là que dans
une vue le film sur carpediem et on
s'est rencontré à paris ils ont fondé
l'association ahmad yens sur laquelle je
me plais coucy et puis on
on a démarré sa pris quelques années à
convaincre le gouvernement français de
mettre sur pied un projet expérimental
parce que c'est ce qu'on fait à
carpediem ça rende pas dans les normes
habituelles
il ya plus que l'accompagnement il ya
aussi la gestion et l organisation et l
architecture et nos recettes sont
autonomes mais il ya les gens peuvent
vivre jusqu'au bout cette année
hier justement une dame est décédée
après avoir fait tout le processus est
décédé à carpe diem avec l'aide des
soins palliatifs du sud on a les gens
peuvent vivre jusqu'au bout avec le
projet qu'on a et et on voit où aussi
suivre les conseils de blandine et des
maisons de kroll parce qu'ils ont
construit une maison une architecture et
on a un projet de construction et on va
s'entraider comme ça et c'est comme ça
qu'on s'est connus et ça fait 10 parce
que 10 encore qu on se voit
régulièrement lorsque vous pouvez déjà
rêver blandine prévaut de votre vie
éventuellement quand la maladie va
continuer d'évoluer à un stade très
avancé
vous savez déjà fait grâce au modèle
carpediem vous allez pouvoir vivre
dignement
j'ai un problème avec ce que vous venez
dire les et j'ai un problème avec le
rêver ok c'est pas c'est pas un rêve
c'est juste le meilleur des avenirs
possibles oui ça c'est certain mais
c'est pas la raison de l'action n'a pas
rêvé d'être d'avoir à vivre ça mais sûr
c'est le meilleur des c'est le meilleur
des avenirs possibles
oui est ce que il semblait plus facile
pour vous quel point de convaincre les
autorités françaises de développer un
tel projet que de d'en développer au
québec moi j'ai eu des témoignages de
gens qui ont essayé d'en développer fils
ait permis une stabilité pelé contraint
d'arrondissement ça n'évolue pas
tellement bien c'est pas facile mais en
france ils ont - ils ont un plat sur la
maladie d'alzheimer un plat globale et
ils ont des mesures sur porte pour
différents aspects de la maladie dont
les personnes jeunes qui sont touchés et
grâce à blandine parce que je pense que
l' approche est intéressante les gens là
la réclame
mais c'est le travail de blandine et
xavier auprès des politiciens qui ont
fait en sorte que la volonté politique
on l'a senti fortement en france et
c'est comme ça que les budgets ont suivi
et c'est avec des fonds publics que les
maisons kroll existe aujourd'hui même
depuis depuis trois ans ils ont
accepter de sortir des clous de sortir
des cadres habituels tout en respectant
la loi et puis c'est ce qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui à des résultats et ce qui
sont intéressants aux maisons kroll tu
peux en témoigner c'est pour ça que ton
avenir
tu peux un peu le visuel oui c'est vrai
je voulais dire par le mou rêve qui
était mal habile vous me pardonnez je
veux quand même qu'on rende sans doute à
travers notre entretien hommage à votre
mari par vos enfants quelle est leur
part dans dans la manière de vivre dans
le choix de vivre et ils intensément
possible
soit on dit que quand on a la maladie
c'est triste moi je trouve que je suis
tellement chanceuse j'ai xavier qui qui
a qui a comment on dit marie wiki à
relever ce défi énorme dans plus de son
boulot de de faire naître ces maisons
c'est énorme qui est ma compagne
aujourd'hui ils ne supportent et puis
j'ai des enfants qui ont vécu avec cette
maladie qui savent où on va puisqu'ils
ont accompagné leurs papilles jusqu'au
bout et c'était aussi beaucoup pour eux
qu'il fallait qu'on trouve une solution
pour qu'ils puissent vivre librement
leur vie et aujourd'hui
main oui on vit ensemble au jour le jour
et puis et puis prennent leur liberté
ils s'envolent
ils savent que je suis bien accompagner
et je serai bien accompagner ce qui leur
permet d'être libre
et cette liberté pour vous ça permet de
s'affranchir de cette culpabilité de
vivre pour vous c'est important oui oui
pourquoi sa part parce que si je ne pèse
pas sur leur vie je n'aurais pas été
comme on dit charlot enfin j'aurais été
une maman et jusqu'au bout voilà
j'aurais été leur maman jusqu'au bout
donc ils sont très bien je devais faire
un suivi de vous et ils sont fiers à
dire des mots de votre part
nicole quand vous voyez les efforts
qu'elle fait pour parler peut-être la
maladie contre les stéréotypes aussi les
moyens mais blandine elle replace la
personne devant la maladie et et ça on
lui doit une fière chandelle de ce
côté-là et de parler de sa réalité
souvent les gens au sport ils ont ils
sont gênés leur donner c'est quelqu'un
qui aimait lire parler et puis elle
dépasse cette gêne là pour pour en faire
une cause et parler et parler sa réalité
csc d'un grain à g grand secours pour la
société je pense vous êtes de grande
complice dans un vrai beau merci
beaucoup et quelques horions merci merci
merci mesdames messieurs à la poche
[Musique]